salut romance à julien c'est quoi un
anus artificiel
tu peux pas dire ça va et toi comme tout
le monde je dirais que l'anus quoi vous
aussi vous vous êtes toujours demandé ce
que c'était vraiment un anus artificiel
ne monte pas je sais que c'est vrai eh
bien il trouve que j'en ai déjà
rencontré personnellement et que je vais
vous raconter
alors d'abord un anus artificiel sa
porte très mal son nom parce qu un anus
artificiel c'est pas vraiment un anus et
c'est pas vraiment artificiel bon on va
procéder par élimination
un anus artificiel c'est pas un faux
than us en kevlar qu'on vous greffe à la
place du vrai quand ils marchent plus
très bien voilà
l'opération s'est bien passée je vous ai
mis un modèle dernier cri un roulement à
billes auto lubrifié wifi et
notifications automatiques prochaine
défécation d'un trois minutes le secteur
plaisir c'est bon un anus artificiel ça
n'est pas non plus une farce et attrape
c'est pas du tout un sextoy
et c'est pas donald trump non lui c'est
un vrai trou de balle tu as compris la
blague alors un anus artificiel c'est
quoi d'abord on dit pas anus artificiel
on dit colostomie où il est aussitôt mis
pour faire simple on veut juste dire ce
tome i
anus artificiel stomie ça vient du grec
ce thomas qui veut dire bush
ouverture à bouche mans en l'occurrence
ça veut dire qu'on coupe un bout de
l'intestin et qu'on lui créer une
nouvelle porte de sortie
c'est une colostomie si on parle d'un
doute colons et une iléostomie si on
parle d'un new deal et on se trouve
juste avant le colon donc le principe
c'est que l'intestin ne voit plus la
lumière du jour par son orifice naturel
l'anus on s'est compris on le fait
déboucher à un autre endroit sur le
ventre en l'occurrence alors vous allez
me demander pourquoi on fait ça mais
pourquoi on fait ça et romain je viens
de le faire là imaginez une famille kaka
qui roulent à toute blinde sur
l'autoroute des vacances et tout d'un
coup paf bouchons routes barrées et tu
petit poucet ta merde qu'est ce que je
peux une stomie c'est un peu
l'itinéraire bis du transit intestinal
quand ça passe plus on prend la première
sortie et comme elle existe pas la foule
a créé alors les bouchons la route
barrée qu'est ce que ça peut être une
occlusion intestinale une tumeur
cancéreuse ou quelque chose qui abîment
l'intestin comme une maladie
inflammatoire ou une perforation après
un accident par exemple dans tous les
cas on doit retirer une partie de
l'intestin ou du rectum
vous savez c'est le rectum c'est juste
avant l'anus c'est la salle d'attenté du
cac avant le grand voyage bref du coup
l'intestin n'est plus relié à l'anus
mais il faut bien que quelqu'un sorte
ah oui ça il faut que ça sorte si on
n'est pas bien du coup la technique
c'est de faire un petit trou dans la
paroi abdominale
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle le ventre
quand on a envie de se la péter ou si on
vit dans un épisode de grey's anatomy
ensuite on prend l'extrémité de
l'intestin on l'a relevé à ce petit trou
et nous voilà avec un anus artificiel
une stèle visuellement ça fait comme un
petit bourgeon qui sort de la peau c'est
de la muqueuse dont il est très rouge
zerah voir sur google images si vous
avez envie on va lancer pas douloureux
sauf éventuellement juste après
l'opération
par contre le problème c'est qu'un anus
de type classique est équipé de cinq ter
ses petits muscles qui vous permettent
de garder vos selles et vos gaz à
l'intérieur de vous lasser si vous avez
un minimum de savoir vivre et bien une
stomie n'en possède pas donc les gaz et
les selles sortent comme ça au débotté
sans prévenir
et alors les selles c'est le nom
scientifique du caca c'est pas le truc
qu'on met dans le bain donc pour éviter
l'inconfort et les drames on utilise une
poche pour accueillir tout ça le
dispositif est assez simple au col un
support autour de la stomie avec un trou
de la bonne taille au milieu et dessus
on vient clip et une poche en plastique
parfois on peut même se passer de la
poche pendant quelques heures il suffit
d'avoir vidé l'intestin avec une
irrigation ce une sorte de lavement pour
ceux qui connaissent ensuite on colle
dessus un pansement avec un bouchon est
la même des et penchent donc on peut
aller se baigner avec alors généralement
à ce stade là viennent les questions sur
les paies et bien la réponse est oui oui
une personnes stomisées c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui porte une stomie et bah
elle pète help route elle lâche des
caisses elles craquent des tôles elle a
du coup on peut dire qu'à peine plus
haut que son cul non alors écoute jeu
j'aime bien l'idée mais fou moi quand
dégage donc c'est peuvent faire du bruit
en faisant vibrer la paroi intestinale
comme les pets tout le monde en fait
mais là c'est d'autant plus gênant parce
que comme on l'a déjà vu la stomie n'a
pas de sphincter est pas 2,5 terre à
contrôler on a affaire à des paies
totalement incontrôlable la solution se
trouve dans le régime alimentaire en
évitant les plats qui donnent des gaz
alors pour l'odeur mais oui parce que si
on veut pas que la poche conçu comme une
baudruche et finissent par exploser ce
qui serait pas très conviviale sur toi
repas de famille je veux bien laisser
sortir les gaz n'a figuré vous que les
poches de stomie peuvent être équipés
d'une soupape pour laisser sortir les
paie avec un filtre à charbon qui
absorbent l'eau d'heure
petite astuce chez vous si vous possédez
un anus de type conventionnel les
filtres à charbon ça existe aussi pour
les slips
vous l'avez compris avoir une stomie
c'est réapprendre à vivre différemment
au quotidien certains finissent par
vivre très bien avec comme les
mannequins b tanit en scène sur twitter
et instagram le hashtag get ur begi out
a permis à de nombreuses tommies est
d'assumer leur stomie au grand jour tant
d'autres comme pour stephen walker c'est
plus compliqué le jeune homme a raconté
sur sa page facebook avoir l'air normal
parce qu une stomie ça se voit pas sous
le tee shirt
ça veut pas dire qu'on souffre pas en
tous les cas un truc qui fait mal et qui
fait peur c'est le regard des autres et
ça on peut il changer quelque chose
parce que le regard des autres c'est le
nôtre en fait
pour finir sachez que dans certains cas
on peut rétablir la circulation entre le
colon et l'anus et supprimer la stomie
qui du coup était temporaire un peu
comme une déviation pendant les travaux
ben voilà ça se débouche allez les
enfants direct sur le soleil voilà
c'était dtc si vous vous posez des
questions sur la santé ou sur le corps
humain
laissez moi un commentaire garder la
pêche et abonnez vous
[Musique]